.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
So sah das Ganze aus.
Das haben wir hier entwickelt.
Alle Zeichnungen selbst gemacht.
Das werfen wir alles weg.
Das ist Vergangenheit.
Arcotronic gibt es nicht mehr.
Ohne Jürg Nigg
würde es wohl keine Sparlampe geben.
Aber jetzt
hat sich seine Welt verdunkelt.
Der Erfinder verlor sein Vermögen
an Internetbetrüger.
Das knickt einen zusammen.
Man fragt sich, was man richtig
und was falsch gemacht hat.
Ich finde es schade.
Man kann schlecht schlafen ...
... und grübelt daran herum.
Was lief falsch?
Wie Gutgläubige betrogen werden
und deswegen alles verlieren,
davon handelt diese Reportage.
Es war vor zehn Jahren,
als wir Jürg Nigg zum ersten Mal
in seiner Werkstatt in Zürich trafen.
Wo ist das Aluminium?
Da fehlt etwas. Ah, da.
Das kommt so.
- Sie haben etwas kreatives Chaos.
Ja.
Bei uns ist alles Chaos.
Braucht man das,
um gut arbeiten zu können?
Entwickler haben immer Chaos.
Mal schauen,
ob die Frequenzkurve gut aussieht.
Inmitten seines Durcheinanders
von Kabeln und Geräten
hat der Tüftler
schon manches erfunden.
U.a. entwickelte der Tüftler
die Elektronik der Energiesparlampe.
In der Schweiz weiss fast niemand,
dass es ein Schweizer war.
Wenige.
Im Erfinderbuch "1'000 Erfindungen"
ist es drin.
Das brachte mir vor Kurzem jemand.
Tut es Ihnen weh,
keine Anerkennung zu haben?- Nein.
Ich weiss, dass ich es gemacht habe.
In seinem Kleinbetrieb entstanden
rund 80 Erfindungen,
die alle ein Patent erhielten.
Das ist ein einfaches Wattmeter.
Das ist auch
eine selbst gebaute Testeinrichtung.
Das ist für Tunnels.
Das sind Blitze.
Die kann ... Nick, bist du da?
- Ja.
Kannst du einen Blitz vorführen?
Möchten Sie das?- Ja.
Das haben wir hier entwickelt,
unser Gerät.
Das ist ein Mitarbeiter, Herr Vitz.
Er testet jetzt ...
... ob das funktioniert.
Noch heute, im Alter von 88 Jahren,
tüftelt er an Erfindungen herum.
Wie immer
bleibt er seiner Philosophie treu:
den Menschen
ein besseres Leben zu ermöglichen.
Das ist eine Trinkwasserflasche
für arme Kinder.
Wenn sie z.B.
kein sauberes Wasser haben.
Täglich sterben
Tausende Kinder in Afrika und Jemen.
Man muss etwas dagegen machen.
Die Flasche
ist seit drei Jahren bereit,
aber ich finde keine Sponsoren.
Die Flasche ist so konzipiert ...
... dass man sie
an eine Autobatterie ...
... anschliessen kann -
an 24 oder 12 Volt.
Dann brennt die UV-Lampe da drin ...
... und filtert alle Viren und
Bakterien da drin zu 99 % raus.
Sodass das Wasser trinkbar ist
und die Kinder nicht krank werden,
und nicht jeden Tag
Tausende Kinder sterben.
Dafür bräuchte man in Afrika ja
Stromzugang und das ...
Ja.
Nein, es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten.
In Afrika ...
... ist vieles sehr einfach.
Sie haben keine Sonnenzelle.
Aber wenn sie eine haben,
können sie die anschliessen.
Sonst müssen sie das Auto nehmen.
Wenn sie keines haben,
können sie ein Velo nehmen
und einen kleinen Generator
auf den Gepäckträger stellen.
Ein Generator ist sehr günstig.
Dann können sie das Velo
blockieren und aufstellen,
und dann mit Treten
die Energie erzeugen.
Es braucht nur 18 Watt dafür.
Wenn sie 10 Min. treten,
haben sie 1,5 l Trinkwasser.
Weil Jürg Nigg auf herkömmlichem Weg
keine Sponsoren fand,
versuchte er sein Glück im Internet.
Ich versuchte es
und schrieb verschiedene Leute an.
Sie meinten, sie würden mitmachen,
aber ich müsse
eine Vorleistung erbringen.
Dann würden sie mich
als Sponsoren unterstützen.
Das machte ich.
Ich verlor insgesamt 185'000 Fr.
Das waren praktisch nur Gauner.
Sie verlangten immer eine Anzahlung.
Ich sage das offen:
Oxfam England ist eine grosse Firma.
Sie schickten mir einen Vertrag,
laut dem ich 970'000 Fr.
als Sponsoring erhalten hätte.
Ich musste ca. 30'000 Fr. für die
Vertragserfüllung usw. vorauszahlen.
Das ging auf eine englische Bank
und ich sah das Geld nie wieder.
Heute weiss er, dass es sich
um gefälschte Dokumente handelt,
mit dem Logo
der Hilfsorganisation Oxfam.
Als er misstrauisch wurde,
stellte Nigg die Zahlungen ein.
Seither wird er von einer Person
mit dem Decknamen Bischof bedroht.
"Der einzige Weg,
um ihr Leben zu retten,
besteht darin, das zu tun,
was ich von Ihnen verlange."
"Sie, Georg und Attie Nigg,
Ihre Frau, und Bruno
werden
bei einem Autounfall sterben."
"Wo immer Sie sind,
es wird nichts ...
... als Unglück sein,
das Ihnen folgen wird."
Warum kam es so weit?
Weil er wollte,
dass wir ihm Geld schicken.
Jürg Nigg erstattete Anzeige.
Doch von den Tätern
fehlt bis heute jede Spur.
Internetstraftaten nehmen laufend zu.
Im vergangenen Jahr gab es in
der Schweiz 24'000 solcher Delikte.
Das sind 6 % aller Straftaten.
Michel Meier, Cyber-Experte bei
der Kantonspolizei Basel-Land betont,
dass die Kriminellen
weltweit operieren.
Sie zu fassen sei nicht einfach.
Die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Europol und Interpol
bezeichnet er grundsätzlich als gut.
In der Schweiz indes
besteht Nachholbedarf.
Es gibt
verschiedensten Handlungsbedarf.
Einerseits braucht es auf nationaler
Ebene eine gemeinsame Datenbank.
Aktuell haben wir noch keine.
Wenn wir ein Delikt haben
und andere Kantone fragen wollen,
ob sie ähnliche haben,
geht das via E-Mail.
Wir schreiben
eine E-Mail an 26 Kantone,
die dann antworten.
ist das einfach nicht so effektiv.
Bis es eine gemeinsame Datenbank
gibt, kann es noch Jahre dauern.
Jürg Nigg hat Besuch erhalten.
Bruno Foser aus Liechtenstein
ist ebenfalls Erfinder.
Auch er wurde mehrfach Opfer
von Internetbetrügern.
Jürg Nigg wurde wie ich
von Herrn Bischof betrogen.
Darum trafen wir uns im Rheintal
und lernten uns dort
persönlich kennen.
Herr Bischof
ist vermutlich in Afrika.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich habe viel Geld verloren.
- Wie viel hat er euch abgeluchst?
Bei mir sind es
zwischen 60'000 Fr. und 80'000 Fr.
Bei mir vielleicht 10'000 Fr.
oder 15'000 Fr.
Da gibt es Verträge. Alles ist da.
- Das war bei mir auch so.
Aber im Prinzip ...
- Die versterben immer.
Gibt es den gar nicht?
- Nein, vermutlich nicht.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Bruno Fosers Unglück
begann mit der Hoffnung,
Geld
für ein Start-up-Produkt zu erhalten.
Bruno Foser
erfand den Pasta-Paolo-Automaten.
Sein Prototyp
steht nun in einem Container,
irgendwo bei einem Bauern
oberhalb des Rheintals.
Das ist ein Pasta-Automat.
Der kocht in 90 Sek. Al-dente-Pasta.
Und zwar aus normaler
Hartweizenpasta, wie man sie hat.
Im Prinzip ist es sehr einfach.
Die Hartweizenpasta
wird im Dosierer vordosiert.
Danach kommt die rohe Pasta
in den Kochkessel.
Und im Kochkessel
kocht sie ca. 54 Sek.
Unter Druck.
Dann ist die Pasta bissfest.
Am Schluss hat man einen Becher
voller heisser Pasta.
Dann ...
... kann man sie
mit einem Löffel essen.
Der heute 60-Jährige
war Inhaber von zwei Firmen
im Bereich Maschinen- und Anlagebau.
Bruno Foser hatte fünf Angestellte.
Heute sitzt er auf einem Schuldenberg
in Millionenhöhe
und lebt von der Fürsorge.
Das ist meine Wohnung.
Hier lebe ich.
Das ist die Sozialwohnung, die man
mir zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
Zum Glück ist sie relativ gross.
So konnte ich meine Sachen
halbwegs unterbringen.
Das ist das,
was von meinem Privatvermögen
übrig geblieben ist.
Diese Elektronikkomponenten.
Plus der Stuhl und die Couch.
Das auf dem Tisch hier -
das ist mein Kraftort.
Hier esse ich,
hier lebe ich, hier bete ich.
Er gibt mir extrem viel Kraft.
Bis jetzt jedenfalls.
Er gab mir auch den Mut dazu,
nicht gänzlich aufzugeben,
sondern weiterzumachen.
Das hier ist ein Foto
zu meinen Blütezeiten.
Ein Foto aus meinen guten Zeiten,
als mein Maschinen- und Anlagebau
noch super lief.
Ich scheiterte ja nicht daran.
Mein Start-up war ja das Problem.
Das war der Grundauslöser.
Das Kapital dafür kam nicht sofort.
Darum suchte ich eine Alternative
und fiel dann
auf die Internetbetrüger rein.
Um den Pasta-Automaten
in Serie herstellen zu können,
suchte er Investoren.
Nebst dem Angebot von Bischof
erhielt er noch zahlreiche weitere
in der Höhe von bis zu 60 Mio. Fr.
Das z.B. läuft seit 2017.
Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich,
dass die Betrüger nicht aufgeben.
Das ist sehr aktuell.
Das kam am 16.9.2021 rein.
Das war vor ein paar Tagen.
Sie schrieben mir, dass ich meine
15,8 Mio. Pfund abholen könnte ...
... ich aber 4'000 Pfund
dafür bezahlen müsse.
Dazu schicken sie Dokumente.
Das ist nur eines.
Wofür verlangen sie denn noch Geld?
- Damit das Geld freigegeben wird.
Zuerst
ging das über die NatWest-Bank.
Jetzt läuft es
über die Bank of England.
Ich bin zwischenzeitlich
aber auch etwas erfahrener.
Aufgrund der Mailadresse weiss ich,
dass das sicher Betrug ist.
Die Mail
kommt nicht von der Bank of England.
Die vermeintlichen Geldgeber
setzten alles in Bewegung,
um Bruno Fosers Vertrauen
zu gewinnen.
Sie luden ihn
zu mehreren Treffen ein.
Z.T. fuhr ich an die Orte.
Turin, Berlin, London ...
Aber im Endeffekt ...
Selbst als ich vor Ort war,
gab es kein Kapital,
sondern ich
musste Vorleistungen machen.
Trafen Sie dort Leute?
- Ja.
Was für Leute waren das?
Das waren Leute, die ...
Aus allen Altersgruppen,
Frauen und Männer ...
... kreuz und quer.
Es war nicht so,
dass man sofort dachte,
dass etwas nicht stimmt,
aber trotzdem ...
... war es komisch, dass man
zuerst Geld aufbringen musste,
um Geld zu erhalten.
Wie viel Geld haben Sie
insgesamt verloren?
Ca. 3,5 Mio. Fr. Privatvermögen.
Wenn man den Firmenwert dazuzählt,
sind wir bei ca. 5 Mio. Fr.
Momentan habe ich
noch ca. 2 Mio. Fr. Schulden.
Im Grossen und Ganzen
war das auch etwas naiv, oder?
Ja, im Nachhinein
kann man das natürlich sagen.
Aber solange das ...
... läuft und einem
immer wieder versichert wird,
dass alles gut sei
und man von Anwaltskanzleien
kontaktiert wird ...
Aber das ist alles nur Fake.
Auch er reichte Strafanzeige ein.
Die zuständigen Behörden
nehmen keine Stellung.
Das Verfahren
sei noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Bruno Foser mag gutgläubig sein,
aber Internetbetrüger
sind mit allen Wassern gewaschen.
Das ist nicht naiv.
Die Täterschaft geht gezielt vor.
Sie passt sich den Opfern
entsprechend an.
Sie verkauft ihnen das,
was die Opfer als gut empfinden.
Z.T.
sind sie sehr geschickt unterwegs.
Wenn man nicht sehr sensibel ist,
kann man wirklich darauf reinfallen.
Die beiden Erfinder
erhielten Dokumente von Banken,
die alle sehr seriös aussehen.
Die kommen
aus London und aus Dubai ...
Und trotzdem sind es Fakes.
Mit der heutigen Technologie
ist das sehr einfach.
Mit Photoshop
kann man solche Urkunden
sehr gut und einfach fälschen.
Diese erweckt dann den Anschein,
echt zu sein.
Vor zehn Jahren war Jürg Nigg
ein erfolgreicher Geschäftsmann,
der in der ganzen Welt herumreiste.
In Sri Lanka liess er die Adapter
für seine Sparlampen produzieren.
Auch leistete er sich Safariferien.
Aber selbst im Dschungel
konnte der quirlige Erfinder
nicht richtig abschalten.
Folgendes: Ich wäre sehr froh ...
... wenn du und Herr Fischer
einen Adapter so ändern könntet ...
... dass man z.B. von aussen
einen zweiten Adapter nimmt.
Das muss man irgendwie lösen.
In seinem Betrieb beschäftigte er
damals fünf Angestellte.
Das ist die gute Seele.
Sie gehört zur Firma.
Sie ist eigentlich Inventar.
Er ist ein Chaot.
V.a., wenn es um die Ordnung geht.
Wenn er den Haufen dort abräumt
oder etwas sucht,
muss man wieder von vorne anfangen.
Der Chef ist ein super Typ.
Er ist super in seinem Metier.
Er kennt einfach
alles aus dem Effeff.
Jürg Nigg war auch sozial engagiert.
Er stellte Menschen ein,
die es im Leben nicht leicht hatten.
Ich hatte finanzielle Probleme.
Ja.
Es hat sich einiges
zum Besseren gedreht.
Er half mir extrem.
Es ist schön hier.
Es ist wie eine kleine Familie.
Passt.
Oh.
Es war eine gute Zeit.
Ein florierender Kleinbetrieb
mit Herz und Seele und einem Chef,
bei dem man wusste, wie er tickte.
Den Adapter ändern wir noch mal.
* Raunen *
Heute ist es still geworden
in der Werkstatt des Erfinders.
Was wurde aus Ihren Angestellten?
Ich musste sie
natürlich sukzessive entlassen.
Es ging immer weiter runter.
Ich verspüre viel Wehmut.
Man fragt sich: "Warum?"
Entlassen
musste er seine Angestellten,
weil Aufträge ausblieben.
Und dann verlor er noch den Grossteil
seines Vermögens an Internetbetrüger.
Das war der Standort meiner Firma.
Da waren wir eingemietet.
Ich und meine Mannschaft.
- Wie viele Leute waren das?
Max. fünf Leute.
Er entwickelte Maschinen
und produzierte Zulieferteile
für Grosskonzerne.
Der Bereich hier war die Werkstatt.
Hier war
unser Show- und Vorführungsraum.
Hier.
Auch privat lief es rund.
Foser war glücklich verheiratet
mit einer Musikerin.
Aus erster Ehe hat er
einen inzwischen erwachsenen Sohn.
Hier waren meine Büroräumlichkeiten.
Wir haben Glück: Die Tür ist offen.
Das tut mir sehr weh im Herzen.
Es stecken so viele Arbeitsstunden
und Emotionen in den Gebäuden.
Wir haben so viel investiert.
Ich als Unternehmer
und meine Mitarbeiter.
Es ist brutal, wenn ich sehe,
wie das alles kaputtgegangen ist.
Ich liess die Storen im Büro
immer unten,
damit ich nicht sehe,
ob es Tag oder Nacht ist.
Ich arbeitete
sieben Tage pro Woche ...
... durchschnittlich
13 bis 15 Std. pro Tag.
Was hielt Ihre Frau davon?
- Meine Frau war ...
... nicht mehr einverstanden.
Wir konnten nichts mehr
zusammen unternehmen.
Durch die Start-up-Gründung
und die Gründung der zweiten Firma
musste ich viel Zeit investieren.
Ich musste die Zeit natürlich
meiner Partnerin wegnehmen.
Das war der Grund dafür,
warum meine Ehe kaputtging.
Momentan ist es relativ schwierig.
Die ganze Geschichte
war sehr nervenaufreibend.
Die letzten fünf Jahre.
Ich hoffe jetzt aber ...
... dass es
in eine andere Richtung geht.
Aber momentan
geht es mir noch nicht gut.
Ja.
* Räuspern *
Wir sind in einer Gegend,
in der es überall Bergspitzen hat.
Ich stand auch schon
auf meinem Hausberg ...
... und dachte:
"Spring."
"Dann bist du erlöst."
"Dann ist es vorbei."
Aber wie gesagt:
Das ist nicht meine Art.
Ich lasse nicht andere zurück,
die mir vertraut haben.
Ich würde sie ja damit
auch komplett schädigen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Zuhause bei Ehepaar Nigg.
Die gebürtige Holländerin Attie Nigg
ist seit über 50 Jahren
mit ihrem Jürg verheiratet.
Im Betrieb ist die 86-Jährige
u.a. für die Buchhaltung zuständig.
Für mich ist das auch lästig.
V.a., wenn ich die Rechnungen
rechtzeitig bezahlen möchte.
Weil er selbstständig ist
und im Moment
gar keine Aufträge hat,
muss ich schon sehr darauf achten,
dass es keine Probleme mit den
Lieferanten, der Suva oder AHV gibt.
Wurde das Geld knapp?
- Ja, das Geld wurde knapp.
Was machst du?
Das Ehepaar
hat eine gemeinsame Tochter.
Sie hat keinen Kontakt mehr
zu ihrem Vater.
Er sei unbelehrbar.
Das findet auch seine Frau.
Haben Sie ihn vor all dem gewarnt?
Natürlich.
Aber er nimmt den Rat
von anderen Leuten sehr schlecht an.
Er setzt einfach seinen Kopf durch.
Er glaubte, das grosse Geld komme.
Er glaubt den Leuten einfach.
Ich habe meine eigene Auffassung.
Man kann sich nicht immer
durch Dritte beeinflussen lassen.
Aber wenn Sie das gemacht hätten,
hätten Sie weniger Schaden genommen.
Wir können ja noch leben.
Aber mit vielen Sorgen.
- Ja gut, wer hat keine Sorgen?
Sind Sie wütend darüber,
dass er nicht auf Sie gehört hat?
Sicher.
- Ja.
Es hat mir ... Es hat ...
Das enttäuschte mich.
Manchmal
war ich sehr traurig darüber,
dass er das trotzdem wieder machte,
dass er es immer wieder machte.
Er hat so viel Geld
an diese Gauner verschenkt.
Er ist so intelligent.
Dass er das selber nicht merkt ...
Ich glaube,
das muss eine Sucht sein.
Er kann einfach nicht aufhören.
So sehe ich das.
Bereuen Sie etwas von dem,
was Sie gemacht haben?
Ich korrigiere Dinge vielleicht,
aber ich bereue nichts.
Wie kann man sich
gegen Internetbetrug schützen?
Man muss dann vorsichtig sein,
wenn das Angebot zu gut ist,
um wahr zu sein.
Wenn es
sehr hohe Gewinnversprechen gibt,
ist das immer ein Alarmzeichen.
Die normalen Investments
haben nicht so hohe Gewinnmargen.
Das ist durchaus ein Signal,
bei dem Alarmglocken läuten sollten.
Und wenn noch Vorschusszahlungen
verlangt werden?
Kann es das geben?
Ja, das kann es geben.
Das muss man seriös abklären.
Man muss vielleicht mal anrufen
und im Internet recherchieren,
was für eine Firma das ist
und wie sich das Investment
darstellt - ob das Sinn ergibt.
Man sollte sich
ein paar Aussenmeinungen einholen,
um abschliessend beurteilen
zu können, ob man investieren will.
Bruno Foser muss mit einem Verlust
von mehreren Millionen Franken leben.
Er schuldet auch
etlichen Bekannten Geld,
weil er sie um Unterstützung bat.
Die hohen Beträge verwendete Foser,
um Vorschusszahlungen
an die Betrüger zu leisten.
Ich lebe ganz alleine,
zurückgezogen.
Ich habe zu niemandem Kontakt.
Ich vermag es nicht.
Ich habe keine Möglichkeiten.
Dadurch
bleibt mir die Sozialwohnung,
die ich habe.
Ich muss in ihr existieren.
Am meisten beschäftigte mich,
dass ich mit niemandem
darüber sprechen konnte.
Sprach ich mit jemandem darüber,
fanden sie, ich sei ein Idiot.
Verständnis
fand ich praktisch nirgends.
Als er noch
ein erfolgreicher Unternehmer war,
scharten sich viele Leute um ihn.
Das war einmal.
Ja, viele haben sich zurückgezogen.
Mein ganzer Freundeskreis.
Und noch tragischer:
die ganze Familie.
Selbst mein Sohn
hat sich zurückgezogen.
Wegen dieser ganzen Situation.
Ich habe zwei Enkelkinder,
die ich praktisch nie sehe.
Wenigstens einen Lichtblick
gibt es bei ihm:
Bruno Foser fand inzwischen
eine Stelle als Unternehmensberater.
Jürg Niggs Sorgen nehmen kein Ende.
Nun muss er
auch noch seine Werkstatt aufgeben,
weil er für sein Haus
blauäugig einen Vorverkaufsvertrag
unterschrieben hat.
Teil des Vertrages war ein Darlehen,
welches er dringend benötigte.
Doch er übersah, dass er
die Liegenschaft im Spätherbst 2021
an die neuen Besitzer abtreten muss.
Was steht in dem Vertrag,
den Sie als Knebelvertrag sehen?
Ich muss zugeben,
dass ich der Firma vertraute.
Sie sagte,
sie vertrete Sozialwohnungen.
Deswegen müsste ich
dann auch nicht lange suchen.
Ich liess den Vertrag
nicht kontrollieren.
Meine Frau und ich
unterschrieben ihn.
Haben Sie damit gerechnet,
dass Sie gar nicht rausmüssen?- Ja.
Die Leute
waren immer freundlich mit mir.
Bis alles erledigt war.
Aber das ist doch auch -
wenn ich das so sagen darf -
ein grosses Mass an Naivität.
- Sehr. Richtig. Das gebe ich zu.
Ich habe mich mein Leben lang kaum
um juristische Dinge gekümmert,
sondern entwickelte etwas.
Das andere kam immer danach.
Das hat mich viel gekostet.
Sie werde immer zu ihrem Mann stehen,
egal was kommen mag, sagt Attie Nigg.
Aber das Zusammenleben mit ihrem Jürg
fällt ihr momentan nicht leicht.
Er habe sich stark verändert.
Er sondert sich immer mehr ab bzw.
die Leute sondern sich von ihm ab,
weil er sich einfach
total verändert hat.
Er ist nicht mehr derselbe Mensch.
Inwiefern hat er sich verändert?
Er ist einfach nicht mehr
dieser positive, lustige Mensch.
Er ist sehr gereizt.
Man muss nur etwas sagen, das ihm
nicht passt, und er flippt aus.
In der Garage
beginnt der betagte Erfinder
mit dem Entsorgen seines Lebenswerks.
Das muss alles weg. Und das ...
Ich habe
mein ganzes Leben gearbeitet
und wollte etwas Sinnvolles machen.
Jetzt kann man alles wegwerfen.
Das ist schade.
Das ist noch lange nicht fertig.
Es hat noch viel.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass ich so viel Ware habe.
Der 88-Jährige schafft das Entsorgen
im Alleingang unmöglich.
Aber die Zeit läuft ihm davon.
Es droht eine Zwangsräumung.
Ein paar Tage später.
Drei Sammler und Elektronikfachleute
machen einen Rundgang
in der einst pulsierenden Werkstatt.
Das sind alte Messgeräte.
Ich machte natürlich Lichtmessungen.
Spektralanalytisch kann man damit
die ganzen Wellenlängen messen
und entsprechend Lampen machen.
Das ist eine Aufdampfanlage, mit der
man dünne Schichten aufdampfen kann.
Hast du keinen Platz dafür?
Dann könnte ich dich aufdampfen.
Das ist ein Wärmeaustauscher
für ein Cheminée.- Der?
Nigg hofft, dass ihm die Männer
ein paar seiner Geräte abkaufen.
Das ist eben von ...
- Was hast du denn da hinten alles?
Wenn ein paar Dinge
mitgenommen werden,
ist die Werkstatt
immer noch nicht geräumt.
Was machen Sie mit dem Rest?
- Wegwerfen.
Leider. Ich habe schon überlegt,
alles nach Holland zu bringen
und dort zu bleiben.
Aber ganz ernst:
Das gibt wohl eine Zwangsräumung.
Auf jeden Fall -
wenn ich nicht mehr Zeit kriege.
Wann müssten Sie raus?
- Ende Monat.
Oh.
- Oh ja. Ende Monat ist ambitiös.
Ja.
Die Besucher
haben Freude an den alten Maschinen.
Die Fleischmaschine
könnte man noch füllen.
Doch, das geht schon.
- Sehen Sie?
Hier kommst du durch, Beni.
Schöne und unverwüstliche Apparaturen
seien es.
Aber gebrauchen könne man
sie hierzulande kaum noch.
Die einzigen, die so etwas nehmen
würden, sind Osteuropäer -
Rumänien usw.
Dort wird man das problemlos los.
Aber man müsste
den Transport organisieren.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass man das verkaufen könnte.
Aber das ist ...
... nicht so einfach.
Es ist Ende Oktober.
Seine Maschinen
wurde er noch immer nicht los.
Jürg Nigg müsste zu diesem Zeitpunkt
seine Werkstatt geräumt haben.
Doch sein kreativer Geist
kümmert sich um anderes.
Ich habe etwas kopiert,
das ich gesehen habe:
was passiert,
wenn man diese Kaffeekapseln öffnet.
Die Farbe der Gehäuse ...
... bildet sich im Kaffee ab.
D.h., dass die Farbstoffe der
Kapseln in den Kaffee eindringen.
Aber das hätte doch Zeit.
Nein, das gehört dem stillen Bürger
in unserem Staat.
Wir müssen darauf achten,
dass wir aufmerksam sind.
Und dass wir mitmachen ...
... wenn etwas nicht stimmt.
Sollten Sie sich nicht darum kümmern,
dass man hier ordentlich räumen kann?
Sonst gibt es eine Zwangsräumung.
Ich bin dran.
Ich habe ihnen geschrieben,
aber leider keine Antwort erhalten.
Was ihm etwas Zeit verschafft,
ist eine Baustelle rund um sein Haus.
So. Gehen wir nach hinten.
Ich kann gar nicht umziehen.
Es kann kein Lastwagen
in den Hof reinfahren.
Alles ist verstellt.
Das ist der Eingang,
das ist alles zu.
Man kommt nirgends ans Haus ran.
Das ist die Treppe.
Bis zum heutigen Tag
fand noch keine Zwangsräumung statt.
Doch weg muss er, das ist ihm klar.
Und so endet diese Geschichte
mit der Erkenntnis,
dass Gutgläubige
viel verlieren können:
Geld - und Vertrauen in Menschen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022